では よろしくお願いいたします
今日のテーマは この基本に戻るという当たり前の人生ということで
あの...ちょっと内容が難しくなりましたので
ものすごく朝 今日ちょっと出かける前にまあちょっと前半を書いておきました
前書きということで 前書きは簡単です
それで前半のスライド何枚かございますけど
まあそれを見てお帰りになってもお休みになっても構いません
この本格的なテーマに入ると
なんかちょっとややこしくなります
で まあ一応ポイントどうしても当たり前のことということなんです
で 智慧のある人の幸福な生き方
当たり前の人生っていうのは
智慧のある人の幸福な生き方なんですね
無知な人が特別な生き方を求めるんです
特別な生き方が結局異常な生き方なんですよ
だから我々はなんか人よりちょっと違った生き方を求めているならば
まあかなり無知という博士号を自分でまあ受け取るしかないんです
で ただ 前書きだから読むだけで十分だと思います
基本に戻ること 朝起きたり
歯を磨いたり 朝ご飯を食べたりする
仕事に学校に行ったり
買い物をしたり 友人と話したり
料理をしたり 掃除をしたりする
まあそんなもんでしょう
当たり前のことは この人生は退屈でしょうか？そこがポイントなんですよ
それ退屈だったら まあ大変なことになります
何か刺激的な大胆なことはないのでしょうかと
大体そういう人々いるんですよ
まあ掃除洗濯ばっかりやってつまらないんだ
人生は なんか他の何かないのかと
それで派手に生きるということ
派手な行為といえば まあ銃の乱射事件のようなものですよ
あれ結構派手ですよ そんなにも派手に世界騒がせたければどうぞ
で まあ銃は持ってないんだからね
ガソリンでもありますからね
あっちこっち撒いて 火でもつけておけば
そんな派手な人生っていうのはそんなもんですよ
そのようなことをする人は派手に生きるのではなく
惨めに死ぬんです 大体誰でも
このちょっと派手に旗を立てて生きようと思っちゃうと惨めに死ぬんです
例えば ノーベル賞を取ったり
金メダルを取ったりする人も
本当は地道に毎日行うべきことをちゃんと行う人なんですよ
では派手な人はいないんでしょうかとかね
総理大臣やらね ものすごい有名な人々とかね
金メダル取る人やら 羨ましいんじゃないかと
何のこともないんです
そういう人々は毎日ものすごい地道に当たり前のことをやっているんです
そういう人々は 自分の当たり前のことをサボることなく
文句言うことなくやった結果
やがてノーベル賞を取ったりするんですね
そんなのはなくてもいいんです
本当は アメリカのブッシュさんには必要かもしれませんだけど
他はノーベル平和賞とかね
取る人々というのはそんなにそれを欲しいと思ってないんです
で 金メダルの場合もそうでしょう
金メダルの場合 皆様知ってるでしょうね
それぐらい派手な人生やってますかと
何の派手もないんですよ
例えば野球選手したっても
毎日毎日地道に訓練して訓練して
プロの野球選手ですけど
毎日キャッチボールやったり
走ってみたりとかね ストレッチングやったりとかいろいろもう地道に頑張っているんですよ
それでもう松坂大輔さんみたいなね
値札がすごい高い人々でもね
お金いくらでもあるんだぞと言っても
自分で飛行機をチャーターしてあっち行ったりこっち行ったり遊んだりするとどうなるんですかね
それで人生終わりでしょう
だから勘違いしてますよ
世の中は 派手に生きようと思って
このアメリカでもね あの最近も乱射事件がありますね
つまらないと それでもうスーパーでね
かデパートか分からないんだけど
人を殺したりして自分は自殺する
だから毎日のことをやればいいのに
我々は決して特別なことをしているのではありません
どんな人も特別なことをやっているわけじゃないんです
これ特別なこと 私が招請状に言ったように
この乱射事件みたいなものなんですよ
他 みんなすごい地道に自分の毎日のことをやっているんです
しかし なぜ問題が起こる？それでも我々の間で
地道に生きてる人々の間でも
問題だけはいくらでも豊富なんですね
それは豊かですね 問題だったら
それは答えは簡単です
なぜ私にお茶を入れてくれと頼むの？私は仕事をしたいだけなのにとかね
私はかっこつけて仕事をしたいと会社に入ったんですけど
お茶入れてくれって言うんですね
それに文句を言うんです
なぜ旦那がお茶 お風呂
お飯自分でやればいいのにとかね
そればっかりやの 何やこれと
なぜ私は省ての看病をしなくてはいけないと
なぜ妻が家のことをすればいいのに仕事をしたがるんですかと
これ旦那が文句言うんですね
なぜ子供のトラブルは自分で解決すればいいのに
会社にまで電話するんですかと
なぜ母親が自分の仕事なのに
僕の部屋の掃除を僕にやられる
僕にやれと言うんですかと
これは母に代わり怒るんですね
それはあんたの仕事でしょうと
電車の座席を年寄りに譲る
恥ずかしい かっこつけていると思われる
そんなできないですよ
恥ずかしいですよ だから寝たふりをする
なぜ老人の面倒を見なくてはいけないの？気持ち悪いし
興味もありませんと なぜ私はこのような昇格もなく
給料も少ない仕事をしなくてはいけないんですか？私はすごい
もうもうもうすごい高い給料の仕事をするはずでしたとかね
私は馬鹿にされると嫌だから仕事に就きたくはない
しかし なぜこの鬼親が部屋に閉じこもらないで仕事をしろと口うるさいんですか？私は仕事したくないんだから家にいるんですけど
なんで親が毎日朝晩いつでもなんか部屋に閉じ込めないで
仕事をしろしろと言うんですかと
お庭や で 他の項目まだたくさんありますので
そこは皆様に宿題として足してください
それが 単純なことをやればいいのに
なんでやらなくちゃいけない？なんでやらなくちゃいけないの？そればっかりなんです
それで答え 何様のつもりですか？それで終わりですよ
答えは 何様のつもりですかね
そんなこと言うの 何様のつもり？ただの人間でしょう
これは以上 すべての文句に不平不満に対する返事です
よくも自分が世界で誰よりも違う特別な存在だと思うことでしょう
よくもノコノコそんなことを思うこと
人間に みんなと私が違いますよって
本当に何様のつもりですかね
私はこういうものだという
ちょっとちょっと間違いですけどね
威厳格の自我を そのもういい加減にね
主張しないで 自我をね
いい加減にやめたらいかがでしょうかと
これ自我主張なんですよ
自分が特別やねん 他のものとは違いますよ
だからもう何もう引っ込むしかないんです
個体としては あるいは銃でもあったら
持って誰 誰でもいいんだから殺してやるとか
そういう文句を言うところから
いかに精神的に我々は悩んで苦しんでいるのかと
だから ついでにそれはあまり文句を言う必要はないんですけど
まあついでに言いますけど
例えば自分の親しい人が誰か亡くなったら
なんでうちの誰か誰か死んだんでしょうか？とか悩んだりするんで
それはまあ自我もそれも自我なんですけど
自分が損しているんだからね
寂しいんだからね まあそれは文句を言う必要はないと思いますけど
まあそれでもまあ世の中に起こることだから
私は特別じゃないんだよと思えば落ち着くんです
自分の家の家族の誰かがね
病気になったり もう治療不可能な病気になったり
死んだりしちゃうと まあやっぱり腹が立ちますよ
これは悩むってもの すごく腹が立つんです
で 泣くっていうことは怒りなんです
だからその場合も まあそこまで今日は言いたくはないんだけど
本当は仏教はそういう時でもいつでも穏やかで落ち着いた心でいることが正しいと
なんで死んだんだろうっていうことじゃないんです
なんで死んだんだろうって聞いたって
特別な人間じゃないでしょうに
だから死にますよ 病気になりますよ
だからその場合でさえも
まあこれは人間にやめてくださいと
家族が亡くなったらね
もう悩まないでください
これは無理な話ですけど
やっぱりその場合ででも理屈は同じなんです
当たり前のことだけ行うということなんですよ
自分の前で人が転げたら手を伸ばしてください
当たり前のことでしょう
これはなぜ私が？何考えてるんですかね
人こけそうになったら
さっと手を出すことでしょうに
これそんなに難しい？自我があるとできないんですよ
自分が特別やと思っちゃうと
人はおはようと言ったら知らん人や
やばい おかしいと病的な妄想をやめて
明朗な声でおはようと言う
これ当たり前でしょうに
どうしたことないでしょうに
上司がお茶と言ったら
部下の後輩の分まで入れてあげて
しっかり頑張ってねと励みなさいと
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ言う
もし私が社長だったらすぐクビにするんで
言わんぞ そんな人間は
だからそういう生き方になったら
いかに楽で幸福になるのかと
何ももう必要ない 当たり前のことを目の前のことをやる
上司がお茶入れてくれって言ったら
まあ自分よりもまあまあ後輩にその時すごい腹が立ちますね
まあ後輩 なんで後輩に言わないんでしょうかとか
余計なことをさっさと後輩のお茶分まで入れ入れちゃえば
入れて あんた方もしっかり頑張ってくださいとかね
言ってあげれば 何のことなく自分が会社は自分が管理しているような状態になるんです
妻が熱を出したら 朝起きて早起きして
自分でご飯を作って子供たちを起こしなさい
こういう男の場合でしょう
毎日妻が作ってるかもしれませんだけど
朝早く起きて子供たちも起こすかもしれません
熱出しているから 何のことなく
そっと自分が早起きして料理作って子供たちも起こしてやれば
いかに人生楽しいでしょうかと
テーブルあるいは床が汚れたら
すぐ他人に命令しないで自分で拭きなさいと
それは当たり前です 他人に物事を頼むと
相手が子供であっても
お願い 頼む やってくれるなどのフレーズをつけるんです
そんな人に命令するっていうことはちょっと良くないです
だから頼むとかね やってくれるとか
私もなんか子供たちに言ったら
一生懸命時々無理なことを頼むんです
それでも一生懸命やってやろうと思っちゃうんです
ある小さな子供に よく抱っこしていたりしましたんですけど
で あの私も疲れたんです
私はね あんたはずっと抱っこしてるんですよ
あんた一回も私を抱っこしてないから
と言ったら一生懸命抱っこしようとするんです
だから楽しいでしょ 子供に大人は抱っこできるわけじゃないし
もう膝よりちょっと背が高いだけで
もうこちら片手で抱っこしますけど
だからまあ命令したらもう大変でしょう
だからまあ言い方が正しければ問題はないんです
自我があると 俺が偉いと
俺が偉い人が命令すると最悪なんです
人が溺れかけたら助けなさい
できないなら助けを呼びなさい
そんなのは当たり前 自分の機関銃を却下されたら微笑みを見せること
自分が一生懸命研究して書いて出したかもしれませんだけど
もうただちょっと挙げただけでそのまま却下だったら
別に怒って笑っちゃえばいいでしょう
実効性がないことはバレてるんですからね
自分の妄想 これまた文章間違いですけど
自分の妄想で最高のものだと
自分では自分書いたものだから
これは世界一立派なものだと勝手に思ったっても
客観的に見るとね 違いますから
人生はすべて当たり前
歯を磨く 用を足すような当たり前のこと
全然びっくりする必要もないし
悩む必要はないんです
何でもかんでもものすごい当たり前のこと
その気持ちでやるとものすごい楽しいんです
俺がやらなくちゃという気分でやっちゃうと
その人ちょっとした思考で人生は地獄に変わるんです
唯我独尊の幻覚 輪廻を脱出してお釈迦様が自分と同じ悟りに達した人はいるのかと一切の生命のことを観察したところで
誰一人も悟りに達していないと発見して一切の生命を見たんです
地球だけじゃなくて 他のところも
自分の能力で見たら誰一人もいないんです
ところで 寂しく唯我独尊と語ったんです
尊尊になったのは私だけかも
それからたくさん聖者たちを作りましたからね
なぜ鉛筆もろくに消すことができない
マニュアルがないと何もできない人間が世間に向かって唯我独尊を
これ嘆くでしたっけ？わめくの
獅子吼じゃないんですよ
わめいてます お釈迦様の場合
獅子吼って言うんだから
この大きい声であれこれやって言ってる人はただわめいてるだけ
それ独裁者でも家でも暴言吐いたり
あれこれただわめいてるだけ
だから何様のつもりで唯我独尊だと思ってるんですかね
これはもう極限に無知なんです
ですから我々は無我で生きるんですよ
無我っていうのは事実なんです
自分というものはないんです
自分とはロボットのように組み立てられた合成されたものですよ
間もないうちに廃棄処分されます
大丈夫です 偉そうな唯我独尊とわめいたっても
みんな廃棄処分されますよ
だから 謙虚で無我の気持ちで生きる人にできないことは何もありません
自我さえなければ なんで俺はっていうこと出てこないでしょう
できますよ なんでも 例えば
あの 100キロぐらい荷物あってね
私みたいな年寄りにこれちょっと運んでくださいと
これはあんまり人を顔を見て頼まないでしょうに
だから頼む仕事っていうのは全部できることなんです
なんで私がやらなくちゃと言っちゃうと
それ自我なんです 自我
それさえなければできないことっていうのはないというということは
何でも上手にできるということでしょう
何でも上手にできるということは才能があるということでしょう
人生成功するということでしょう
当たり前のことを行う人は
この世で成功を収め あの世の幸福
幸福も確保し 解脱も解脱にも達するのです
お釈迦様おっしゃっている悟りに涅槃に達することさえも
当たり前のことをやるという方式なんです
全然大胆なことはない
特別なことって何もない
あ 終わった はい そういうことが今
この前書きで本格的にテーマにはこれから入ります
はい